Republican Congressman Steve Scalise is
breaking his silence for the very first
time since he was shot the House
Majority Whip was critically wounded as
you know at a congressional baseball
practice back in June and he spent weeks
in the hospital
Scalise had multiple surgeries and
suffered a serious infection since then
he has undergone extensive physical
therapy to learn to walk again Norah
spoke with Scalise for Sunday's 60
minutes she's with us now from Capitol
Hill Norah good morning hey good morning
remember when we covered that live all
the way back in June well now for the
first time the House Majority Whip is
talking about what exactly happened on
that day we got to talk with congressman
Scalise and his wife Jennifer about what
happened and also about his grueling
road to recovery it was just after 7:00
a.m. on June 14th at a ballpark in
Alexandria Virginia when a team made up
of Republican congressman went from
shagging balls to dodging bullets okay
that guy was Congressman Steve Scalise
this cell phone video was among the
first images of him that day
last was him being wheeled on a gurney
to a helicopter
clinging to life he spent most of the
next four days unconscious I found out
later just how much damage was done
internally you know I mean my femur was
shattered the hip and pelvis had serious
damage where the bullet went through and
you know did some damage to areas that
had to be shored up with steel plates
and and and they did a phenomenal job of
rebuilding you know kind of the
rebuilding Humpty Dumpty I mean there
were there was a lot of damage inside
that that had to get fixed they put you
back together again back together
talk about that rebuilding for this 51
year old not only all of the surgeries
that he went through
but then the rehabilitation the recovery
learning to walk again so we're gonna
explain all of that walk it through on
sixty minutes and it's an incredible
story when we also talked to the doctors
who really saved his life Charlie gale
Vienna yeah thank you Nora rebuilding
Humpty Dumpty I think he might have a
new nickname but he looks and sounds
pretty good did you find that to be the
case
he sounds terrific he has a wonderful
family who really stuck by him and he
was doing rehabilitation seven days a
week and the doctors had to stage an
intervention they said you know what you
need to take Sundays off so he has been
working really hard to try and get back
on his feet literally and to try and get
back to work all right thanks a lot Nora
you can watch the interview with House
Majority Whip Steve Scalise Sunday night
on 60 minutes it airs after football
right here on CBS